all right the mainstream media the mob
no
well their hypocrisy knows no bounds nbc
being called out
two very different tweets one praising a
protest in brooklyn
with no social distancing the other
slamming president trump's
planned oklahoma rally uh even websites
like mediaite
and some others they are taking notice
of well that massive hypocrisy here with
reaction white house press secretary
kelly mcinerney
first of all i don't know what you get
paid you're way underpaid
number two i could never do your job
number three you're doing a great job
considering the
conditions you work uh with the mob
let's talk i mean those two tweets
what was it within an hour right okay i
think it speaks volumes
less than an hour and a half cbs had a
rendition of the same
tweets and look this is so inherently
contradictory this is how
much they have trump derangement
syndrome they see a million people
registering for a rally so they're so
contradictory praising the crowd of
protesters
criticizing the million people who
signed up for a trump rally
we saw this with the churches when
president trump opened the churches
socially distanced
they criticized that but then at the
same breath lauded the protest a week
later
it is so wrong the people see directly
through this and it's all because
president trump's succeeding okay let's
now
go to all of these issues now the
president
we didn't have any reforms after
ferguson after baltimore after cambridge
that was on barack and joe's watch
now the president is going to put in
reforms um no other president
like a lot of issues he's he will do
what other presidents can never get done
criminal justice reform opportunity
zones lowest unemployment for every i
you know every demographic in the
country historic lows i expect the v
recovery now he will deal with issues
more training what can we expect from
the president
yeah this is a big deal sean you're
exactly right when you say for eight
years
president barack obama and vice
president joe biden couldn't get it done
but takes a businessman like president
trump to come in and say
how can i do this creatively in a way
that protects police officers but also
is real substantive change
this will be an incentive structure for
police departments across the country to
implement
correct training so that things like
what we saw with george floyd
never happen again that tragic killing
but at the same time
funding our police officers bolstering
them not defunding them
as the despicable congresswoman like aoc
and ilhan omar have suggested we should
do
okay defund dismantle dissolve okay i
i i that's not going to end well kaylee
you don't need to be a brain surgeon at
all to see that
now we also know for example
governors refused to ask for the
president's help
they have to ask for the help unless if
it gets so bad then the president will
use the 1807 insurrection act which
even attorney general barr says he has
the right to do but
only if it gets to that point we're not
at that point in my opinion but we might
if this keeps going on
yeah what we're seeing in seattle's
despicable look over my shoulder
when the dc mayor the liberal dc mayor
got a chance to control the streets that
she's supposed to do
this church burned saint john's church
burned officers got injured
when president trump came in and said
enough is enough the national guard is
being surged
it was a different scene in d.c
president minneapolis correct
and minneapolis that's exactly right but
what we're seeing in seattle
is grotesque taking over six blocks of a
city
defunding police through the anarchical
actions
of a mob it is and the governors have to
ask the president
that's right and they won't because
they've got a liberal governor